[Musique]
olivier dufresne maréchal faire
j'étais propriétaire de chevaux j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à la
maréchalerie en regardant le maréchal
ferrant qui venaient chez nous puis en
voyant mon intérêt il m'a suggéré
d'aller à l'école le parage du sabot
c'est la première étape
après six semaines d'un repos c'est
assez importante que ça va influencer
les muscles les tendons tout l'appareil
qui tiennent le squelette ya trois
raisons pour lesquelles on faire un
cheval la protection du sabot on à la
traction
puis on a des problèmes orthopédiques on
a notre bon vieux marteau pour couper
les clous
[Musique]
pour arracher les clous
on voit un fermoir et sur l'image c'est
un phare qui donne du sport à l'arrière
du pied
chaque frère doit être ajusté au sabot
certains jusqu'où ont besoin d'être fair
et lorsqu'il travaille beaucoup
leurs propriétaires de leur cheval plus
que 5 6 fois par semaine
plusieurs heures avec un terrain très
abrasif effectivement il faut protéger
la corne
la plupart des chevaux qui sont sur un
terrain plus loin très bien du pied
avant d'être maréchal ferrant j'étais en
boulangerie en fait je travaille à
l'intérieur avec de la farine et puis
les horaires ont fait en sorte que j'ai
voulu sortir
puis elle dort un des avantages de
maréchal ferrant c'est quand on gère un
peu son horaire de métier assez risqué
c'est un métier qui demande un calme une
connaissance des animaux pour voir venir
certains dangers
[Musique]
un jeune cheval c'est normal qu'ils
soient un peu énervé j'étais nerveux
c'est bien différent
il faut leur assurer le calme est ce que
j'aime tant des chevaux c'est peut-être
un certain calme qu'il faut avoir au
travail c'est sûr qu'on peut oublier
puis est un peu stressé mais il faut
depuis le début des temps on s'est revus
l'humain puis les premiers qui ont
réussi à maîtriser la maréchalerie sont
allés beaucoup plus loin
les armées qui il avait des eaux qui
était pas fair et éventuellement dans
leur avance vallée qui attendent que les
sabres pouce parce que les chevaux
devenait trop sensible les armées qui
était ferrée ont pu continuer appuyez
gagner des batailles la cause de tout ce
que j'aime des chevaux c'est la liberté
que ça représente
il faut aimer l'animal il faut aimer
l'odeur la sensation parce que c'est
plus qu'un travail c'est un mode de vie
maréchal ferrant on en fait c'est toute
une vie donc il faut se rapprocher des
animaux puis peu à peu mais chaque
personne va découvrir son chemin depuis
les premiers jours c'est un métier qui
me passionne et puis plus on en apprend
plus on se rend compte qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses à étudier puis plus on fait
des connexions plus on a envie d'aller
voyage et puis visité puis à prendre
ah ah
[Musique]